jean jacques et séverine travail
méticuleusement depuis juin dernier ces
deux résidents de les actes de charlieu
fond de l'ensachage pour la minoterie
moniot des sacs d'un kilo destinés aux
particuliers
pourtant contours de leur le leur moi je
mets les étiquettes sur le sachet est ce
jeu l'école après pour l'établissement
cette nouvelle activité est un plus pour
former les adultes handicapés
chaque semaine une tonne de farine est
ainsi conditionné dans ce petit atelier
c'est une activité intéressante puisque
nous cherchons des activités pérennes
dans tant de partenaires à ses proches
de chez nous privilégier quand même
aussi les circuits courts et en même
temps un travail qui soit adaptée à
notre population qui souvent surprendre
les personnes puisque après une période
d'observation n'apercevant s'aperçoit
qu'ils ont des grosses grosses capacités
en termes d'attractivité au travail et
savoir faire
à l'initiative de ce projet la minoterie
moniot une entreprise familiale créée en
1836 et qui favorise depuis longtemps la
solidarité les circuits courts
ici tout le blé vient d'exploitation
situées à moins de 120 km de la société
notre volonté c'est vraiment de
travailler en circuit court
aujourd'hui on interagit sur 21
départements autour du moulin et donc
notre c'est notre coeur de métier c'est
l'artisanat qui on travaille
et puis là aujourd'hui on a vraiment un
vecteur un vrai potentiel de la part des
particuliers avec une très très forte
demande notamment
la part de la grande distribution sur un
sur ce sur ce créneau là du 1 kg dans
cette minoterie cinq générations de
meuniers se sont succédé l'entreprise
réalise aujourd'hui un chiffre
d'affaires de 5 millions d'euros est
très douze mille quintaux de blé par an